- Welcome everyone.
It is an absolute pleasure to introduce
our speaker this afternoon,
who is going to be part of our
Distinguished Franke Speaker Series.
And our guest today is no
one other than Carl Zimmer.
Most recently, the author
of the book "Life's Edge,
the Search for What it Means to be Alive."
But before I tell you more
about Carl and the many books
that he has written,
and the many ways in which his
writing in the New York Times
over the past two years,
has enlightened, informed,
and taught us about the COVID epidemic,
how it's unfolding, what we
need to do to protect ourselves
and the evolving, scientific
understanding of the pandemic.
Let me start out first by
saying a few thank yous.
I'd first like to
recognize our benefactors
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
who have been ardent supporters
of Interdisciplinary Activities at Yale,
beyond the Franke program in
Science and the Humanities.
We are deeply grateful to them,
for the support of all
the exciting ventures
that the Franke program has
undertaken since its inception.
And I'm also delighted to report that
they are in attendance today.
So welcome Richard and Barbara.
I also want to take this
opportunity to thank Ty Kamp
for helping organize this
talk and all the series
that we have been holding
so far and Guy Ortoleva
for his help with recording
and making these recordings
promptly available and
accessible to many people
beyond those who can join us today.
So we are recording this event.
So I would like to all participants
to leave your videos muted
for the duration of the talk.
Please go ahead and submit
your questions at any time
in the Q and A feature
on the chat and we will
present these questions
to Carl at the end.
So now let me move to
telling you a little bit more
about our speaker today.
So Carl, as you all know,
reports from the frontiers of biology,
where scientists are expanding
our understanding of life.
And I mean, life in the
fullest possible sense.
And the New York Times has called him
the countries' most respected
science journalists.
And many of you can
also attest to the fact,
as I mentioned before,
that in the past two years,
what he has done has been invaluable
in helping us stay on top of COVID.
He's been reporting for the
New York Times since 2004,
where he now writes
his wonderful weekly
column called "Matter."
And his writing has won many, many awards,
including The Stephen Jay Gould Prize,
which is awarded by the Society
for the Study of Evolution
in recognition for individuals
who sustain efforts
of advanced public understanding
of evolutionary science.
In 2021, he was a member of
the team at the New York Times
that won the Pulitzer
prize in public service
for coverage of the COVID 19 pandemic.
Of course in addition to his reporting,
Carl is the author of
14 books about science.
This's just incredible.
He's such a remarkable
writer with his insight,
with his clear explanations, I mean,
it's an absolute joy to read his books.
And I have to gush here
that the first book of his,
that I actually read
was the one on viruses,
which of course I reread
during the pandemic.
His latest book is "Life's Edge:
The Search for What It Means to Be Alive"
and it's a notable book,
as picked by the New York Times for 2021.
It was a Finalist for the PEN/E.O.
Wilson Literary Science Writing Award.
And so a little bit of his path.
He started his journalism
career at discover,
where he went on to work for
five years as a senior editor,
he's written for many other magazines,
including the "National Geographic,
Wired, The Atlantic and in
2003, he launched the Loom,
an award-winning blog, which
has been hosted by discover
and national geographic.
In 2015, Carl became a
contributing national correspondent
for STAT, a publication
about health and medicine,
where he hosted,
"Science Happens," a video
series that was a finalist
for a national magazine award.
In 2019 Carl Zimmer created what is life,
an eight episode series
of life conversations
with leading thinkers about
why life exists, how it began,
and other big questions about existence.
He's a three time award winner
of the American Association
for the Advancement of
Science Journalism Award,
twice for his work on the New
York Times, once for the Loom,
he's won the National Academy
Science Communication Award.
So the list of awards just goes on and on,
and I will sort of briefly
truncate it and just move on
to tell you a little bit
more about his books.
So in 1998, he published first book,
"At the Water's Edge: Fish
with Fingers, Whales with Legs,
and How Life Came Ashore
But Then Went Back to Sea"
And since then he has
written these 13 more books,
for which he has once again,
won fellowships from the
Guggenheim foundation
and the Sloan foundation.
In 2018, he published, "She
Has Her Mother's Laugh:
The Powers, Perversions,
and Potential of Heredity.
The guardian named it the
best science book of 2018,
and the New York Times
book review named it
a notable book of the year.
He's also won the 2019
Communications Award
from National Academies
of Science, Engineering,
and Medicine and Science and
Society Journalism Award.
Amongst his other exciting books,
the one that I have particularly loved,
is the "The Tangled Bank: An
Introduction to Evolution"
which was the first
textbook about evolution
ever published, intended for non-majors.
And it was named an
academic title of the year.
One of the reasons I'm
sort of going through a map
of his writing is to show you his range,
depth and versatility in
terms of the kinds of topics
and the genres in which he has
communicated so effectively
with various sectors of the public.
He also co-authored, "Evolution:
Making Sense of Life"
which was now a textbook
for biology majors.
And it was co-written with
the University of Montana
biologists, Doug Emlen.
And this is a book, they said textbook
that is continually being
updated with new editions.
And I think the fourth
edition is now in preparation.
Carl is a popular speaker at
universities, medical schools,
museums, and festivals as
you can probably imagine,
high demand and has also,
you've probably also heard him
on Radiolab on This American Life!
So he is the only writer after whom
both a species of tapeworm and
an asteroid have been named.
So without further ado, as you can see,
I'm very gushy about Carl's writing.
I would, like to turn it over to Carl.
Carl, we are delighted
to have you here today.
- Thank you so much Priya.
It's really great to be here.
Thanks for having me, and
it's an honor to be part
of the Franke Lecture Series.
I wanted to talk today about
life, I mean, as you had
indicated in your introduction
there, life is kind of
my, as a journalist,
is my beat as it were.
And, but I wanted to
sort of talk about life
in the big picture rather than,
just one particular
fascinating aspect of it.
So let me just share my screen,
I also wanted to thank that
Franke for this poster,
which is just gorgeous, and it's,
sometimes you look at a poster
and you're like, oh, they
picked some weird photograph
just to catch your eye.
But this actually has a
lot of meaning for me,
and a lot of relevance to my
most recent book, "Life's Edge"
because this thing that
you're looking at here,
this is not out of some
science fiction movie.
This is could be out of your backyard.
This is an animal called the tardigrade,
and here it's being photographed on,
it looks like a bed of moss, probably,
maybe grazing on a little algae.
Tardigrade are incredibly common animals,
but very weird animals and
weird in a way that's actually
like helps us to really think about
what we mean when we talk
about something being alive,
like a tardigrade.
So,
the,
so tardigrades, they're not
visible to the naked eye,
they're very small.
You need at least a crude
microscope to see them.
And so people didn't know about that,
were all surrounded by tardigrades
until the 1770s Actually.
There was a German
preacher who named Johann August Goeze,
I'm probably not
pronouncing that correctly,
my German is not great.
Anyway, so Goeze was a
preacher who in his forties
discovered natural history
and just jumped into
it with a huge passion.
He actually collected,
he collected tapeworms
and he had such a fantastic collection
that the emperor of
Prussia bought it from him.
I didn't know that Prussian emperors
had an interest in tapeworm
collections, but this one did.
In any case, he also
saw at a friend's house,
a microscope and was
immediately taken with it.
Microscopes had been in use
for a century at this point,
but people were still using it
to discover new things.
And he got himself a microscope,
this is actually his microscope,
and started looking at stuff.
A lot of what he would
look at would just be,
water from a pond in his backyard
and things like that.
And he really marveled at this,
he said a glass lens shows us a new world.
And I know from experience that,
you'll be full of amazement
when seeing that for the first time.
He was really quite taken
with what he was seeing.
And one of the things that really,
really impressed him was this, (giggling)
this is his, his own
drawing of this creature,
which we call a tardigrade.
Tardigrade is from the
French, it means slow walker,
but actually Goeze didn't call it that,
he called it a water bear.
He said, "Strange is this little creature,
because the whole organization of his body
is extraordinary and strange."
And he said that, "At
first sight has the closest
similarity to a little bear.
This also led me to give him
the name, little water bear.
And then later he says,
"One can hardly imagine
something more horrible
than our little creature
appearing in the size
of a real bear."
That would be quite something.
But in this world, water
bears are quite tiny.
And so Goeze was observing
it through his microscope.
And he was struck by these
eight little feet that it has,
which are each armed with three claws.
And it was moving around
under the microscope.
He wrote his movements I
observed were always the same.
He was on its back,
continually stretching out
and retracting his feet as if he wanted to
try to grasp something to get on his feet.
So here you have a
naturalist who's observing
a creature in action.
The classic thing that
naturalists do with life.
So now, we're, it's about 250 years later,
and we know a lot more about tardigrades.
We know that they are not just in ponds,
not just on moss, there are
tardigrades in the ocean.
There are tardigrades all over the place
and they're incredibly
diverse group of species.
And we can actually watch them walk,
not just be on their back,
flailing their legs around,
but this is actually
one of the first movies
of a walking tardigrade.
And they're not that slow for their size,
they move pretty quickly
on those eight legs.
So they clamber around.
They are animals that move,
and they move towards things,
usually they're moving to eat.
They're finding something to eat,
whether it's algae or
some single cell thing.
And as tiny as tardigrade may be,
they have a remarkable internal anatomy.
They're surprisingly a lot like us
as bizarre as they might
look on the outside.
Sure, they have eight
limbs instead of four,
but they have a brain
and they have a mouth
and, they have a nervous
system and they have muscles,
even if salivary glands and so on.
You can see they have
reproductive organs as well.
So here's yet another feature that shows
that they are like us, living things.
And living things as a rule reproduced,
this is actually
slightly scandalous video
of water bears having sex.
This is how they do it.
The male transfers sperm to the female,
and then after fertilization
the female produces eggs,
which it then lays, then
all those little eggs hatch,
and now you have more tardigrades.
So, I think we would all
feel very comfortable
to say that tardigrades are alive.
I doubt that there would be many people
that would dispute this.
It seems obvious.
I mean we don't even have
to discuss what we mean,
when we say that something's alive.
And yet tardigrades can
do some remarkable things
that actually challenge
our comfortable assumptions about life.
So if you were to become dehydrated,
let's say you lost 5% of
the water in your body,
you would feel terrible.
You lost 10%, you would feel worse.
If you start losing 20% and
more you're going to die.
That's it, you can't survive.
And if I were to pour
water on you after that,
you would not suddenly like
sit up and start talking.
You're gone.
You've died from dehydration.
That's not true for the tardigrade.
So the dehydration,
desiccation, drying out,
that's a regular part
of being a tardigrade.
It's just that they're in
environments often where,
where they're going to get dried out.
And when that happens, they
don't just become sort of
a shriveled version of themselves.
They go through a very remarkable change.
So this is from an article,
an American scientist
from a couple years ago.
So on the top, it shows
a regular water bear,
below it is a water bear
that has been dehydrated.
And this strange little shape
it's called a tun, T-U-N.
And,
there's nothing going on in there.
Tardigrades have to have to
breathe, these don't breathe.
Tardigrades have to eat,
these tuns do not eat.
They do not excrete
waste, they do not move,
they look like a grain of sand.
And yet, if you were to
pour water on that tun,
it would swell up and it
go back to looking like
the tardigrade grade at the top there.
And you could wait quite
a while to do this.
actually you could wait decades,
and scientists have, they have,
stored away tuns in collections.
And eventually people have said,
"Here's a tardigrade tun
that's been here for 30 years
or 50 years, let's see what
happens if we put some,
put it in water and more often than not,
they're able to come back.
And they really look very much like,
just an ordinary tardigrade.
Just walking around, eating,
just in the sense being alive.
And what's incredible
is that this capacity
it makes tardigrades
unbelievably tough, resistance.
They can be blasted
with levels of radiation
that would kill any other
animal many times over,
they've been sent into space,
actually in this little craft
they were shot into
orbit and the tardigrades
that were sent up there
they were actually exposed
to just the vacuum of space.
And they wrote around
like that in outer space,
no space suit and came back
to earth and then scientists
were able to revive them again.
So these tardigrades are one
of the most extraordinary
creatures on earth and so
scientists are wondering,
well, how do they do this?
How is this possible?
It's a very complex process
that they've evolved.
So the first step is actually
to avoid the damage that
comes with dehydration.
So the problem with getting dehydrated
is that all of our proteins and our DNA,
they really need to be in
water to work properly.
And so once water levels
start dropping down,
proteins can get misfolded,
there can be molecules
that clump together,
and things just stop working.
So tardigrades do this amazing thing
where they they make a huge
amount of a special sugar
come all trehalose and they
basically replace the water
in their cells with trehalose
and they can kind of
shrink their cells down.
So this is part of the reason why,
a tardigrade becomes really
tiny when it becomes a tun.
But that's just the start actually.
So they then, look at this diagram
which is really complicated
is just reflects
all the things that are happening
inside of this animal's
body as it turns into a tun.
You see a little line there vitrification.
Vitrification you might
think of like glass,
and that's kind of what happens actually,
that it makes a bunch of
proteins that wrap around DNA,
mitochondria, all sorts
of different structures,
and freeze things in place
and protect them from damage.
So essentially the tardigrade is becoming
a kind of a protein glass.
And like, so if we think of metabolism,
for example, as being
like essential for life,
these tardigrades aren't doing it,
their proteins cannot move.
They cannot react with
each other, that's it.
And they can stay like that,
in this estate for decades.
So,
is the tardigrade that's
become a tun, is it alive?
Well if we turn to
dictionaries for some help,
it's a little difficult.
So you have a definition here.
The first one, the quality
that distinguishes a vital
and functional being from a dead body.
Well, what's that?
I mean it's almost kind of circular.
You're saying that life is something
that living things have.
Okay?
The second one is a principle or force
that is considered to underlie
the distinctive nature of animate beings.
What is that?
This principle, it sounds
almost like alchemy,
C is a little more concrete,
an organismic state
characterized by capacity,
for metabolism growth, reaction,
stimuli and reproduction.
Okay, I mean, we can get
our heads around that
scientifically, but does a
tardigrade tun metabolize?
Nope, can't eat.
Can't produce waste.
Doesn't do those reactions.
They just do not happen.
There's no water there
to allow them to happen.
Can it grow?
Nope, perfectly fixed in size.
The cells do not divide because
they can't do metabolism.
Do they react to stimuli?
Well, with the exception of adding water,
no, they just, it's essentially
like a grain of sand.
Can they reproduce?
Absolutely not.
So, we're left here with a very
frustrating situation where
we have something that
in its ordinary form,
we would agree is alive, it's alive,
but can go into another state.
A state that really does not
fit our definition of life.
I'm sort of reminded of all the terrors
that humans have had about
being buried prematurely,
because people are worried that
they might go into some sort
of deep sleep or some type of state
that would be mistaken for death.
But in the case of tardigrades,
it's very similar in some ways to death.
Scientists don't call it death,
they call it cryptobiosis,
which means hidden life.
So cryptobiosis which other
animals can do as well,
is in a way sort of taking life
and sort of tucking it
away in a safe place.
But the fact is that,
by a lot of the sort of standard
ways that we talk about life,
a tardigrade can stop being
alive, and then be alive again.
The there's another example, that's,
it's also really fascinating
in a puzzling way.
And that's viruses.
This is a reconstruction
of the SARS-CoV-2 virus,
which causes COVID 19.
So if like me, you've had COVID,
you had a billion of
these things inside of you
replicating away
and they're,
tardigrades are small viruses
are much, much smaller,
but obviously, size doesn't
really take away from the,
the power that they can have.
I mean, this little virus
has turned our whole world
upside down has wrecked Global economies,
probably killed about 18
million people so far worldwide.
And aside from the very
practical specifics
of what viruses do to our lives,
they're really very puzzling
in and of themselves.
Like, what are these things?
Are they alive?
We couldn't even begin
to ask these questions
until people had found viruses
because viruses are so much
smaller than tardigrades.
It took even longer for people to be aware
that were surrounded with them,
that they're inside of us.
So tardigrades were found in the 1770s,
viruses really weren't recognized
until for about a century later,
a little over a century later.
Obviously there were diseases like rabies
and influenza that made people sick,
but people couldn't say that's
a virus, that's causing it.
That's something that
belongs to this class
we're gonna call viruses.
It actually wasn't a human virus,
that was the first one
that was discovered.
It was actually a plant virus.
Tobacco farmers in Europe,
we're dealing with a disease
called tobacco mosaic disease.
And it would cause these
splotches that gave it its name
kind of like a mosaic.
And so some scientists
like Martinez Beijerinck
figured out how to do an
experiment to understand
what was causing the disease.
They thought, well, maybe
it's a fungus or bacteria
because by the late 1800s,
the germ theory of disease
was becoming pretty well established.
So what they did was they were
mash up a sick tobacco leaf
and mix it with the water,
and then pass it through a filter.
So that big clumps of
stuff couldn't get through
you just only small
things could get through.
And they would inject it that
fluid into a healthy plant,
and then they would see that actually
that plant got sick as well.
So that suggested, yes,
there was some kind of germ
that was causing this disease.
So then, Beijerinck actually
used another filter,
a very, very fine filter.
One that was where the pores were so small
that bacteria and fungi
could not get through.
So he did the same experiment again,
mashed the lead, mixed it with water,
pass it through a filter.
Now he's got something that
really just looks like water,
and he takes that and he
injects it into a leaf
and lo and behold the leaf gets sick.
So he's saying, well, there's
something else out there,
something other than bacteria and fungi,
I'm gonna call it a virus.
So this is the first time
the word virus is used
to describe these invisible
agents of disease.
Couldn't see them, it's
not like he was Goeze
looking through a microscope
at his little lovely little water bears.
He just, he could see the
effects of the viruses,
but they were too small for him to see.
This remained the case for decades.
Viruses remained invisible,
scientists were now able though to
conceptually understand viruses
and could then look for human viruses,
Like for example, influenza.
And,
and so still though, the
microscopes of the early 1900s
while they were much better
than the ones that Goeze had
in the 1700s, they still
just weren't powerful enough
to see a virus.
So Wendell Stanley had
this interesting idea.
He knew that you could make crystals
out of different substances,
we're familiar with salt crystals,
but you can actually make
crystals out of proteins too.
They under the right conditions,
they'll come together in this sort of
some repeating pattern.
And if a crystal gets big
enough, you can see it.
You can shoot x-rays at it
and figure out its structure.
So I thought, well,
there's some indication
that viruses have protein in them, so,
why don't I make a virus crystal?
So he grows a lot of tobacco mosaic virus,
and tobacco plants, concentrates them,
and then he sees lo
behold that these little
spiky shapes start to form.
They start to become big
enough that he can see them
with the naked eye and
he can collect these
and store them just, on a shelf, in a jar.
And it's kind of like, cryptobiosis,
he can like take them off
the shelf months later
and put them in water and let
them infect a tobacco plant.
And they cause just as
much as disease as before.
So, this idea that something
that seems like it's alive
can be a crystal, like salt,
this is kind of mind blowing.
And when Stanley published his results,
the journalists
reporting on this really had a hard time
keeping their composure.
So the New York Times,
they would talk about this,
how this staggers the imagination,
the viruses they're
neither dead nor alive,
kind of like a tardigrade tun.
And they seem to lie on that shadowy
borderland where matter is
ready to leap into life,
which is a line I just love.
The subject really just for
years kept obsessing people,
and actually in 1940, a few years later,
there was another article
which had a section
that was headed, "Can Crystals Live?"
and they talked about
Stanley's experiment.
And they asking, were
these crystals alive?
Apparently no more so
than diamonds, glass, sand
or other crystals with
which we are familiar.
Yet when virus crystals
were put on a tobacco leaf
that mosaic disease
spread like a slow fire
over a whole field,
just as if it had been
infected by living bacteria.
So, very early on, even before
we really knew very much
at all about viruses,
people recognized that
they posed a huge challenge
to our concept of life.
So finally microscopes
caught up with the viruses.
So electron microscopes made it possible
to actually visualize
viruses for the first time.
This is what tobacco
mosaic viruses look like.
They have this interesting
cylindrical shape,
what's inside of them?
What are those cylinders made of?
Well, Rosalind Franklin,
who might be best known
for her work on the structured DNA,
before that, had actually
made a name for herself
by studying tobacco mosaic viruses.
And actually doing really important work
to figure out what are
these things made of?
What are viruses made of?
And it turns out that,
that a tobacco mosaic virus
is made of protein here,
their blue and violet
show different proteins that
are kinda locks together.
And they hold
genetic material, in the case
of tobacco mosaic viruses,
that material is RNA.
We keep our genes in DNA,
which is a double strand.
There's some viruses that
also have double stranded DNA,
but a lot of them, a
lot of viruses have RNA
for genes instead, that's one strand.
So COVID 19 is caused by an RNA virus.
The flu is caused by an RNA virus.
Tobacco mosaic disease is
also caused by an RNA virus.
But what's really
interesting here is that,
it's just, this protein is just a package
and it's just carrying these genes.
It doesn't even contain
enzymes that you need to copy.
their genes like we have.
It's just a delivery system.
Now it turns out that that
shape of tobacco Mosaic virus
is not the rule for viruses.
And, as you can see here, in this diagram,
you have viruses that
are like soccer balls.
Some, some are like snakes.
Some look like weird little spaceships,
they're all very small,
but they have this incredible variety,
that could literally trillions
of species of viruses on earth.
We don't know, we've barely
scratched the surface
when it comes to their diversity.
(Carl coughing)
But in spite of all the diversity,
there are a lot of things that unite them.
In some ways, if you've seen
one virus you've seen them all.
Again in the sense that the
viruses are not like cells.
So they're not little
chambers full of metabolism
going on inside,
a cell can grow, a cell can divide,
a cell can copy it's own DNA.
Viruses can't do any of that.
They're just a protein shell
with genetic material inside.
And so Peter Medawar a famous immunologist
of the 20th century said
that they were simply
a piece of bad news
wrapped up in a protein.
That's a good way of
summing up what a virus is.
So what this piece of bad news does
is infect cells and get the
cells to make more bad news.
In other words, the protein shell
will have receptors on its surface
that can let it latch onto a cell
and deliver its genes inside the cell.
And the cell's own
machinery reads those genes,
makes proteins and those viral proteins
basically take over the cell
and cause the cell to make new viruses,
which then escape the cell
to go in infect other cells.
So just with real basics
there of what a virus is,
we have the question again,
as we had with tardigrades and
their tun is a virus alive?
Now I showed you the
dictionary definition before
scientists actually have,
will come up with their
own definitions of life.
And I would say that the most influential
is one that a group of
scientists came up with for NASA
sorry about that, in the early nineties.
They were having a
meeting about exobiology,
about finding life on other planets.
And they were like, wait,
we need to agree on what
we're looking for, right?
And so they had a spent
all day arguing over this,
argued over dinner, and
by the end of the day,
by the end of the evening,
they had settled on a working definition.
I write about this whole process
in my book "Life's Edge."
I said, "Life is a self
sustained chemical system
capable of undergoing
Darwinian evolution."
So short, sweet, clear, good writing.
And as I say, very
influential, like you'll see
this definition or versions
of it around a lot.
So we have these viruses,
Darwinian evolution.
That's a big part of the definition.
They certainly are.
We're dealing with the Omicron variant
of SARS-CoV-2 right now,
variants are produced through
evolution, through mutations,
through natural selection.
So now we know Omicron is far more fit
than the first viruses
that emerged in China.
It has evolved a lot, since
it became a human pathogen.
So no question that viruses
are capable of Darwinian
evolution, there are
the textbook case of it.
However, what about being a
self sustained chemical system?
Well, there are chemicals in it obviously,
but self sustained, in the sense of like
being able to feed itself
to expel ways to maintain
an internal environment.
Nope, can't do it.
It just doesn't do it.
So, here we have something
that straddles the definition,
which meets a definition halfway,
is it half alive?
Can we have such a thing?
Gerald Joyce is a scientist who
helped to come up with his
definition and wrote about
how they came up with a definition later.
And a reporter was asking
him about that experience,
and brought up viruses.
And Joy said to the reporter,
according to the working definition,
a virus doesn't make the cut.
So sorry, viruses, they're not alive.
Now, when I talk about this
in my book or in lectures,
scientists sometimes will reach
out to me, and they'll say,
well, of course Joyce is right.
I mean, viruses are not alive.
I mean they just don't
have those essential things
that make life possible.
And then I will also hear
from other scientists who say,
well, this is ridiculous.
Of course, viruses are alive.
You can't understand them
without thinking about them
as evolving living things.
I literally got two emails in the same day
where I was being told that viruses were
and were not alive from scientists.
So this is still a live wire issue.
I think one of the most intriguing ways of
addressing this and
challenging Joyce comes from
someone named Patrick Forterre.
He's a French virologist.
And he, you could kind of think of the,
of viruses according to Forterre,
a little like the tardigrades
in the sense that like,
tardigrades can be in
two different states.
So you've got the regular
tardigrade walking around
and then you've got that tun.
So a virus that's floating
around outside of a cell,
think of that as kind of like a tun,
it's got a genetic
material inside and so on,
but we wouldn't really not really alive,
but once it gets inside of a cell,
things are very different.
It's not so much the
virus itself that's alive,
but it is the merger of
the virus and the cell.
So an ordinary cell,
Forterre calls it a Ribocell.
And that it's because they have ribosomes,
which are these factories that they use
to make proteins based on their genes.
But the cell is making
proteins for its own needs.
If a cell gets hot, it can
make proteins that will help
to protect itself against heat.
It can make proteins to
stick on its surface to grab
different kinds of things
that it needs to survive.
So a cell can look out
for itself as it were.
Now, once a virus gets into a
cell, as I mentioned before,
all of a sudden there are
all these virus proteins
inside of it.
And these viral proteins,
completely change what the cell does.
In the case of COVID For example,
if you get COVID
the cells that are infected
with SARS-CoV-2 inside your body.
They can no longer make
their own proteins.
The virus proteins plug
up those ribosomes,
and they only let virus genes in.
Virus RNA can go in to the ribosomes.
So it's like the worst
bouncer at the club door.
It's not gonna let in
RRNA, it's only gonna
let in the viral RNA.
And so in other words, the cell's purpose,
the cell's function has changed,
and he calls it a virocell.
And in that regard, Forterre
says viruses are alive.
And it's easy to sort of to,
to miss just how much a
virus changes the cell
once it gets inside,
so I mentioned it
plugging up the ribosomes,
here the ribosomes are shown in purple
in this computer image
of an infected cell,
but these yellow things,
these actually represent bubbles,
that the virus creates
inside of an infected cell.
So the cell is full of these bubbles,
and inside of these bubbles
gets, put new viral RNA.
In other words, genetic
material for new viruses.
It builds up inside of these
little nurseries, and then,
it gets more later,
could then get packaged
into new viruses to leave.
So again, like if you look
inside of an infected cell
of virocell, it just doesn't
look like an ordinary cell.
It looks like a different kind of life.
And so Forterre who has a
neck for the product says,
whereas the dream of a normal
cell is to produce more cells
the dream of a virus is to produce
a hundred or more new virocells.
Now, I don't know when
this debate's gonna end,
and I'm not sure maybe it
can end in the way that
people are conducting it.
And, to sort of explain what I mean,
I wanna just jump back again to the 1930s
back when viruses were
a deep, deep mystery.
Norman Pirie, who was
a British virologist,
who did a lot of important
work on tobacco mosaic virus
and other viruses,
he wrote about this exact same question.
He said, "When one is asked
whether a filter-passing virus
is living or dead, the
only sensible answer is,
I don't know."
We know a number of things they will do,
and there were things that it won't
and if someone will
define the word living,
I will try to see how the
virus fits into the definition.
So Pirie sort of recognizes that,
we are trying to pretend
that there's a scientific,
a clear scientific
question to be addressed
without recognizing that the
language that we're using
to frame the question is actually really
problematic in some ways.
If someone will define what
living means to me, well, gee,
I gave you the NASA definition of life.
I gave you the Merriam Webster definition,
but there are lots of other definitions.
These are actually like taken
from the scientific literature
and these are just a tiny
sampling, there are hundreds,
several hundred published
definitions of life,
different ones, and more
get published every year.
So, if Norman Pirie
was waiting for someone
to give him a very
clear definition of life
that he could work
with, just to figure out
if viruses are alive or not,
well, 80,90 years later,
we're still waiting
for that kind of clarity.
And maybe that this buzzing
confusion of definitions
tells us something.
That's the argument that Carol Cleland,
a philosopher at the University
of Colorado has made,
and she wrote a book a couple years ago
called the quest for
universal theory of life,
where she lays this out.
She lays it out as a philosopher.
And the key point that she makes is that,
we should not be searching
for a definition of life.
In fact, definitions
of life get in the way
of our understanding of life.
And that might seem weird,
I mean, how can you,
understand, study something
that you can't even define?
That sounds like mystical,
but it's actually not.
The problem is that, definitions,
philosophically speaking, are
ways of organizing concepts
and Cleland points out that, let's say,
what is a bachelor?
You can define a bachelor,
because all you're
doing is you're relating
different concepts to each other.
So a bachelor is an unmarried man.
Well, what does it mean to be,
there's no question about that.
Now, what is marriage?
Well, that's complicated.
What is a man?
That's complicated too.
And so there are things
that can be easily defined,
cleanly defined and things
that are much more problematic.
And if you focus on trying
to find just the perfect
definition, you may not
be spending the time.
You need to really understand what it is
that you're dealing with.
So an example that she gives is water.
Okay?
So what is water?
How do you define water?
Well, 500 years ago if you went
and talked with alchemists,
they were the ones who
understood what we call
chemistry best, and they
would define it for you
as being transparent, as being liquid,
as being able to dissolve certain things,
they'd give you a list of characteristics.
But that very problematic, because
for example what happens
when water gets cold
and suddenly you have
a solid, is ice water?
Well, no, not according to the definition.
Then you would have
these different kinds of
transparent liquids, like
could dissolve things,
but some could dissolve some things
and some could solve other things.
So are they all water?
Alchemists would try to deal with this
by calling some things
Royal water, for example.
Which we would know to be
certain kinds of acids.
Even Leonard Da Vinci at the time
was just left mystified by water.
So you would talk about how
water was sometimes weak
and sometimes strong, sometimes
bitter, sometimes sweet,
sometimes thick or thin,
sometimes bringing hurt or pestilence,
sometimes health giving.
So it suffers changes in as many natures
as are the different places
through which it passes.
So Leonard Da Vinci would not have gotten
any greater clarity, just
trying to come up with
a definition of life.
What was needed was 300 years of research
of experiments of thinking and theorizing,
and coming up with a theory of matter
in which you could explain water.
So once you have the language of atoms,
molecules, elements, and so on,
you can think about water in terms of H2O.
And you can think about water
as being molecules in motion.
and at certain temperatures
that becomes ice.
So that yes, ice is water,
sure of course it is.
And it's not so much that you're seeking
to define water now, you're
just trying to understand it.
You're trying to see how water
behaves in different ways
and make predictions about it and so on
and use it in interesting ways
that you hadn't expected before.
So this is the difference
between a definition of life
and a theory of life.
We don't have a theory of life,
but what would it be like?
Well, it would be a way
to explain how matter
takes on certain properties and we could
debate what those properties are,
but what I like is the
analogy of super conductivity
over a century ago, scientists discovered
super conductivity, it was very weird,
there were these substances
that lost their resistance
to electric current.
When you got them very
cold, didn't make sense.
Einstein couldn't explain it,
Richard Feynman couldn't explain it,
but eventually some folks got together
and made a theory of superconductivity.
A theory that explained it in
terms of pairs of Electrons
And now it made sense.
Now you could see how different substances
could actually be superconductive,
and that then allowed
people to start making
new kinds of superconductive material.
So, and you could start making things
that could support trains, for example.
So it's a theory that we
need, a theory perhaps about,
organization and information.
Maybe that's something that really is
what needs to be explained for life.
Just to give you one example,
there's a theory called Assembly theory
that Lee Cronin at the
University of Glasgow
has been exploring.
So it's not about the
specifics of DNA and protein,
but maybe just about
the steps that it takes
to make molecules.
So maybe what's distinctive
about life is that
life and only life can
make certain molecules
that require lots and
lots of steps of assembly.
And that it's a simple idea,
but it's actually a potentially
a very powerful one,
because, maybe you don't
need to know in advance
what living things are
made of on other planets.
You don't need to be just
looking for DNA based life.
Maybe there's on a moon like
Enceladus over at Saturn,
maybe life is totally different.
Maybe assembly theory can
help us to understand it.
And it's possible that maybe life isn't
going to be discovered on another planet.
Maybe, someone in a lab was gonna make it.
These are little droplets
of mixtures of oil
that actually Lee Cronin
and his colleagues
have have produced
Just mixing different things
around you get droplets
that do weird stuff.
He refers to them as unstable proto cells.
They move around, they divide,
they do lifelike things.
They're very strange, I don't
know, we quite call them life,
but they might be telling
us something about
how living things first arose.
And we could theories to
understand what we're looking at.
But this really takes us back 250 years
because when I think when we're looking at
these amazing experiments,
like what's happening in this dish,
I think we're kind of like Goeze was,
where he talks about a glass lens,
that shows us a new world.
I think that we in a
sense are looking at life
for the first time, with
this new perspective.
And we're just beginning to
maybe to be understanding it
in this new and profound way.
So thank you so much for your time
there's lots more about these issues
in my book "Life's Edge"
and I'm more than happy
to take questions if people have them.
- Thank you so much Carl
for that wonderful talk,
outlining the complexities
of the semantic definition
of what life is because of,
the biological, chemical
and other properties that
we attribute to life forms.
And this is a question
that's of great importance,
even in the space sciences at the moment
where people are trying to understand
if we do discover signs
of extraterrestrial life,
what might that look like?
And then of course, we
may have to even expand
beyond the idea of carbon based
life which is where we are,
fighting over the definitions on earth.
Thank you so much for that wonderful talk,
so let's give Carl a clap, a virtual clap
before we open up for questions.
So I think we have a few questions
that have come in to the chat.
The first one is from Seana,
who would like to hear your thoughts
on the theory of symbiogenesis,
taking more of a center
stage in common knowledge
and the future role of quantum mechanics
in explaining question in biology.
- Wow, well a great question.
Yeah, so symbiogenesis is this
idea of different organisms
or different living systems
coming together in a symbiosis
to create new levels of life?
So for example, the best example would be
in our cells we produce
fuel in mitochondria,
and those mitochondria, basically
are little house guests,
they're bacteria that
took up residents inside
of our single celled ancestors
maybe I guess about 2 billion years ago,
something like that, and,
there was a mutual benefit
there in the sense that
the bacteria were getting shelter
and they were getting some
provisions and then they could,
actually produce things like
ATP fuel for the host cell.
And eventually it became
impossible to distinguish
the two of them there became
just one greater unit.
And when people like Lynn
Margulis were arguing for this
in the sixties, it was
fairly controversial,
it wasn't clear how important it was, but,
along with mitochondria, there
are lots of other examples,
whether you're talking
about the chloroplasts
that make plants green or actually insects
insects and other invertebrates
have lots of bacteria
inside of them, the bacteria
actually inside of their cells
and can only live there and
they have this remarkable
symbiosis, so like cicadas for example,
which we have these
emergence of cicadas and,
the cicadas are eating fluid
from trees and there's not much
nutrient in it and on its own
the Cicada couldn't survive on it.
But you feed that to the
bacteria that it harbors
and the bacteria can actually
build essential amino acids
and then give them to the insect.
And so you have a symbiogenesis
right there as well.
I don't think that symbiogenesis
will necessarily tell us
that much about the very origin of life,
just because you need
those complicated things
to begin with, to have
them to come together,
bacteria already pretty complicated.
But it is possible to think about,
people think on the early earth,
the earliest life forms might
have had RNA inside of them,
or maybe just RNA floating
around and sort of oily layers
at the bottom of ponds
or something like that.
So you could have different RNA molecules
cooperating with each other
in a kind of molecular
symbiosis that's possible.
As for quantum mechanics
I mean obviously like when you get down
to the level of atoms,
quantum mechanics matters,
I don't know, I mean when I
started as a science writer,
over 30 years ago,
people were talking about
the revolution of quantum mechanics
to change the way we
think about biology and,
it's important, if you're
understanding like vision
and for example, in levels
of energy levels of photons
and so on but I don't think
that, I haven't seen much yet
in how quantum mechanics really changes
the way we think about
important kinds of biology,
or principles of evolution, but we'll see
the guy could change.
- So somewhat related to
that Carl, I had a question.
So I mean, in our view
of evolution, right?
It's very much driven by
this idea of competition,
and so as you just mentioned, right?
So isn't there and sort of an
emerging understanding now,
on competition and cooperation,
both being elements of how
evolution actually operates?
- Sure and Darwin was
intrigued by cooperation
from the very start of evolutionary theory
and I mean he certainly was aware of
they have the importance of cooperation.
I think that,
I mean, basically, there are
situations in which cooperation
is going to be the most
advantageous evolutionary strategy,
and there are gonna be situations
and for certain organisms where it's not.
So,
when SARS-CoV-2 is
infecting us for example,
and you get mutant variance
popping up inside your body,
there is a competition going
on among those viruses.
It's sort of unconscious competition.
It's not like a race or something.
It's just like the question is, well,
the viruses with different mutations,
which ones will make the most viruses?
And then over the long term,
the mutations that increase
the fitness of viruses the most
may become the ones that are dominant.
On the other hand, the
fact is that viruses,
this is kind of weird, but
viruses do sometimes cooperate.
They actually work together
to different kinds of viruses
will get into the same
cell at the same time
and manipulate it together
using their pooled resources,
to make more of each kind of virus.
So, that's, you're still getting sick.
So that cooperation isn't
very warm and fuzzy for you,
the sick host, but, it's
pretty cool that the viruses
are cooperating as well.
So they're both definitely
important for evolution.
- Great, thank you.
So we have a question
now from Deepti Pradhan
who writes the famous Tilde Science Café,
and her question is where
would one play viruses
on the tree of life?
- Great question, yeah, so the
tree of life was this image
that Darwin invoked in
the origin of species,
because he saw species as
sharing a common ancestor,
involving splitting all
off from a common ancestor,
like branches on a tree.
And so we share an ancestor
that lived maybe six
or 7 million years ago with chimpanzees.
We share an ancestor that maybe lived
10 million years ago with gorillas.
Those that are our
closest living relatives
and for animals like you
can make a whole tree
like showing how animals are related
and descend from a common ancestor.
There was a primal animal,
from whom we all descend.
And that's all animals,
that's tardigrades,
and jellyfish and sharks, all of us.
And if you step back further,
we share a ancestor with fungi,
and if you step back even further,
we share a common a we share with plants.
So we're closer cousins
to fungi than plants.
It's something that's
worth bearing in mind,
step back even further, and
you can start to see how
we're related to protozoans
and then to bacteria.
So all cellular life can pretty,
pretty well be organized
on a tree of life,
looking at their genes and comparing them.
Then you got viruses.
What do you do with these things?
How are they related to if
at all, to anything else?
The part of the problem is
that viruses are so small
and they have such tiny genomes
that there's just not
that much information
to link them to anything.
So it's very hard to know,
I mean you can tell how viruses
are related to each other,
but it can be very
challenging to link them to
the rest of life.
But there are some clues as to how,
genetic material from cellular
life may be able to break off
and become viral.
And in fact,
it goes the other way as well, that,
we have been infected by viruses,
our ancestors for millions of years.
Some of that viral DNA
has been incorporated
into our genome.
So we're about 8% of our
DNA comes from viruses.
So,
it's possible viruses where there
at the very beginning of life,
maybe viruses started
out as parasitic RNA.
We don't know.
So viruses may sort of like
hover around the tree of life.
Maybe that's the best
way of thinking of them.
- Thank you, I think you've definitely,
shown us the paradoxes
of how we could deal with the viruses.
So the next question is from Agatha,
which of the definitions of life resonates
most closely with you and why?
- Yeah, I know, like it
sort of depends on the day
I write about the creator
of one of those definitions
in the book named Albert Szent-Györgyi.
He was a Hungarian Nobel prize winner.
He won the Nobel prize for
discovering vitamin C basically.
And once he had won the
Nobel prize for vitamin C,
then he decided, well, okay,
now I can get down to
some really serious work.
And so he really wanted
to get down to the very
nuts and bolts of life,
really like life itself
on a sort of biophysical level.
And he did amazing work.
He actually got, he was in Hungary and,
and was starting this research,
right when world war II breaks out.
He becomes a spy, he joins resistance,
and he's on the run around Hungary,
but he would show up every
now and then unexpectedly
in his lab, to make sure the
experiments are going okay.
Where they're trying to understand
how muscles fiber works.
'Cause he really feels that
that's gonna give the key.
And then, he actually
then smuggles it out.
He gets a Swedish diplomat to smuggle out
the manuscript about
these findings because
he's terrified that no one's gonna know
about what they found.
And a lot of people think
maybe he should have gotten
a second Nobel prize for that, but,
he joked afterwards after that work
and after the war that he was
working so hard to figure out
what life was but it was just
sort of, it kept escaping him.
And after a while, he was just like, well,
I'd like to call life a play of water.
Because he was interested
in the way in which,
a lot of the key reactions,
that happened in his cell
involved water molecules,
being broken up and being used
to carry out these reactions.
So he just said, life
is just a play of water.
So I can live with that.
- So the other question,
the next question is even from Mada Suden,
who says, even
self-sustaining living systems
cannot be a closed system.
They need external sources of energy.
If you put things in that way,
is a virus that different?
They need external matter to
exhibit other signs of life.
And they're asking for your comment.
- Yeah, I know, that's a
very interesting point.
I think in biology, there's been
a very long running division
between parasites, and,
"Free living hosts"
and but you're right, like, I mean,
who is really like totally
free living Like, I mean,
we depend on other living things,
we all carry around a microbiome.
We'd be very sick without it, and so,
so I agree that it's, we
can't be too contemptuous
as there were are viruses,
but I still think that
the fact remains that,
viruses are really different than cells
in some fundamental ways.
But who knows scientists
are finding some really
weird viruses these days,
like really big viruses
with loss and loss of genes.
And some of those genes seem
to encode for parts of cells,
like ribosomes or parts of the
apparatus for photosynthesis.
So, there's some weird things
about viruses, I'm sure will
find viruses that really,
defy our easy definitions even more.
- Thank you, thank you.
So there's a comment from Gary who says,
What is life?
The question needs a
context on who is asking
that in what domain
and the important issue
is knowing the mechanism
as to what is going on
in a particular domain and
then you can assign terms
either new ones or old
ones to different parts
of the process, to
further experimental work.
- Well, certainly it helps to,
it can be useful to have
working definitions of life,
for particular work,
the working definitions.
So if you wanna go and find,
alien life and you're gonna spend
hundreds of billions of dollars
trying to do it, like it might
be nice to be able to know
what it is that you're even
thinking about finding.
But even then I talked
to an astrobiologist
of who appears in the book,
Laurie Barge, and I said to her,
so she's in Enceladus
which I shared before
this moon of Saturn, she'd
really liked to go to Enceladus
because it's got covered in ice,
but it clearly has a lot of
weird chemistry happening
inside of its liquid ocean.
And I'm like, well, what's
your definition of life?
Like, what would it have to be
in order for you to say it's alive?
And she's like, I prefer not
to deal with things like,
I don't like to define life.
This is literally an astrobiologist,
his job is to find life.
She's like,
I'd like to go there and
see what the chemistry is.
And I bet it's very interesting
and I'll just wanna
understand what it's doing
and what makes it interesting.
And maybe eventually
we might come to agree
that there's something there we call life.
But what if it was chemistry
that in 10 million years
will give rise to life, like
you wouldn't wanna just dismiss
it out out of hand before.
So it's interesting even astrobiologists
sometimes don't wanna define life.
- Thank you, Carl.
The next question is from Brian,
are there genetically similar
creatures to tardigrades?
If so, do they display the
cryptobiological process?
- So tardigrades are
just, they're animals.
They're,
I forget what their scientists are always
trying to figure out how
an closely different parts
of the animal kingdom are
related to each other.
So, I think they're kind of
closely related to insects
as I recall now, but, they're
their own branch, but,
so they share a common ancestor with,
with other animals like us
that have, brains and guts
and nervous systems and so on.
Now cryptobiosis, what they're able to do
is actually found in a number of animals,
lots of little invertebrates that do it,
and fungi and bacteria
seem to be doing
something similar as well.
So what's interesting is that,
I showed you the tardigrade strategy,
which is essentially to
like just replace your water
with sugar and then turn your body
into basically a protein glass.
That's one way of doing it.
Other branches of the
tree of life have evolved
other strategies to do the same thing.
But the result is the
same that these things are
somewhere between life and death,
and can stay that way for decades
as far as we can tell.
- Great, the next question is from Diane.
So since prions lack genetic material,
is there consensus that
they're not alive.?
- Again, it all comes down
to what your definition of life is.
And so,
they are again kind of like
a they're at "Life's Edge"
they might fulfill some parts of the
of common definitions
of life and fail others.
So for example, so prions are
proteins, just naked proteins,
but they are sort of
deformed versions of proteins
that we make ourselves.
And so if a prion version of
the protein comes up next to
a regular version, it
can deform it as well.
So now that we call that a prion.
And then that can deform another protein
and so on and so forth.
So that can lead to diseases,
like mad cow disease
that people have gotten from
eating contaminated beef
or lamb, deer suffer from a prion
called Chronic Wasting Disease,
which is a big problem.
Deer hunters are aware of that.
But again, it is just a
protein that it can reproduce.
Well, it doesn't make a
new protein from scratch.
Neither does the virus.
All the SARs-Cov-2 in
the world is made by us,
it's made out of human molecules.
And so, it's sort of weird,
like we think of this thing as a virus,
but it's manufactured out of human parts.
So I don't know.
So, it's is making another
molecule take your shape?
Is that what we call that reproduction?
It's very hard to say
and yet it has some lifelike properties.
So again, it's not really the answer isn't
maybe we shouldn't be
thinking sort of either or.
I know we like to think of life or death,
something's alive or it's not,
but we have these very fuzzy cases
that are interesting
because they're so fuzzy.
Right.
- Thank you.
So the next question is
from Steven, who asked,
it seems that exceptions
have been the most helpful
in trying to establish a rule.
How do the characteristics
of mitochondria support
or fail to support their
candidacy for life,
especially given their supposed origins?
- Yeah, so, I could have spent,
the hour talking about mitochondria
instead of tardigrades or viruses,
'cause here we have
another fascinating example
are mitochondria alive?
We probably all agreed
that their ancestors
2 billion years ago were alive,
in the sense that other bacteria
floating in the ocean are alive.
They were able to metabolize
and reproduce and evolve.
What's kind of amazing is that
actually inside ourselves,
still mitochondria divide,
they're sort of like
doing their own thing.
The mitochondrial
division and cell division
are kind of tied together but not totally.
So different cells have
different numbers of mitochondria
in them, which is interesting.
So they're still doing
part of what we think of as being alive.
But the fact is that if
you look under the hood,
if you open up my
mitochondria and look inside,
they still have some genes.
I forget the number,
something like 30 genes.
So they have some DNA inside of them.
And those genes produce proteins
that do incredibly important things,
we get really sick of those
genes that are mutated.
Those genes descend from
the genes that were carried
by free living mitochondria.
But those mitochondria had
thousands of other genes.
So where'd they go, well,
some of them were lost
that just didn't need them anymore.
Some of them actually ended up getting
moved from the mitochondria
into our own chromosomes,
into our own DNA.
So we have some, and
along with a viral DNA,
we have some bacterial
DNA in there as well.
So you have this thing like
if you take mitochondria
and pluck them out of a
cell and just put them
in a Petri dish and say like, okay,
on your own, like they're dead.
They can't do it.
And yet there's nothing more important
to our own life than mitochondria.
You shut mitochondria down, we're dead.
Some of the most potent poisons
work by shutting down mitochondria.
So, I have no idea if you called
mitochondria alive or not,
it's really up to you, but
it's really interesting
to think about how it compares to things
that we're more comfortable calling alive.
- Thanks, Carl, I think true
to your book's title, right?
There are many questions
that one can ask about
the edge of what counts as life
and how we define that edge.
But before we close
this wonderful session,
it is too tempting to let
you go before asking you
what you think is coming next with COVID
with our pandemic, are we
in for another or minor wave
unnoticeable wave, noticeable wave?
- Well, we're two years into this pandemic
and I find that the smartest
scientists I talk to
are also the most humble.
They really respect this
viruses capacity to surprise us.
Nobody saw Omicron for example coming,
like no one had said like
we're gonna have something like
Omicron until we had Omicron.
So, people keep saying like,
oh, that's it we're done.
Or, "Oh, virus has always
evolved to get milder"
Oh, the virus has run
as far as it can go."
And I honestly don't think
that we know that or not,
and that's not a happy,
that's not a happy thought,
given all the suffering
that it's caused us already.
But I, this right now, today
as we speak there is this
sub variant, a sub variant
of Omicron called BA2,
which is has become dominant.
Most cases in the United States are that,
but cases are still pretty low in the US.
And, it's possible that this
is going to give us a bump.
But on the other hand a lot of people
have already been infected recently
or they've been vaccinated
so they may reign that in.
I don't really think we know.
I mean, we will know in
a week or in two weeks
about this one, but my question is
what happens in six months?
- Yeah.
- It seems like every
six months or something,
we get an Alpha, a Delta, and
Omicron, a really big thing.
Are we gonna be due for a new one?
There's certainly lots
of viruses out there
that are evolving, so
there might be another one,
there might be another one in the works.
And, if we're, if things work out for us,
our vaccines will continue
to protect us against it.
But, if we sort of dropped the
ball on vaccine development,
we could be looking at a
new form of SARs-Cov-2 that,
our vaccines are just
not really good against.
So it's been a long two
years, but I just don't,
I see no reason to just get complacent.
- Gosh, sounds like we
need to be conscious,
and this pandemic could
just ooze on its way out.
And maybe, I guess the,
well let's not leave it
on a pessimistic note though,
we might have this with
us forever, but anyway,
thank you so much Carl
for taking the time,
to talk to us today and thank
you for all the wonderful work
that you do, making the
science in particular
during this pandemic
intelligible to the rest of us.
So, on behalf of the Franke
program and our audience today,
I'd like to give you a big warm thank you.
- Thanks so much for having me.
It's been a lot of fun.
- And thanks everyone for attending.
We have a couple of events coming up next.
We are gonna continue
virtually on Zoom through
to the end of this semester.
And we have have our next
talk on the Mapping series,
which is coming up,
which is by the
musicologist Victor Coelho.
And then we have two talks coming up
by our own Franke Fellows,
Franke graduate fellows in April as well.
So we have a rich program
for now next month,
the Mapping as knowing lecture
series talk by Victor Coelho
is on Tuesday, April 12th,
and the talks by our Franke Fellows,
Anna Florence and Diego
Ellis-Soto are on April 19th,
sorry, April 20th and dates to be decided
for later on April.
Anyway, I would like to thank everyone
for attending and look
forward to seeing you
at the next events.
And thanks again, Carl.
Bye.
- Bye bye.